et
j'accueille l'invité politique du jour
c'est christophe béchu le nouveau
ministre délégué en charge des
collectivités territoriales il est
également maire d'angers est également
secrétaire général du parti horizon
d'edouard philippe bonjour christophe
béchu bonjour alors merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation je crois savoir
ce que c'est d'ailleurs votre première
intervention dans les médias depuis
vente votre entrée au gouvernement nous
sommes ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse quotidienne régionale qui est
représenté aujourd'hui par le groupe la
dépêche du midi avec vous christelle
bertrand bonjour jean christophe
christophe béchu on va commencer par
l'audition du jour au sénat audition du
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
et de la ministre des sports amélie
oudéa castéra sur ce fiasco de
l'organisation de la finale de ligue des
champions au stade de france samedi soir
à saint denis alors gérald darmanin il
pointe la responsabilité des supporters
britanniques et des milliers de
supporters qui sont arrivés sans billet
ou avec des faux billets mais quand même
est ce qu'il n'ya pas aussi une
responsabilité de l'état et notamment
des forces de l'ordre dans la stratégie
de sécurité
il m'a semblé que c'était précisément à
ça que devait servir les auditions
parlementaires de cet après midi il voir
clair est ce que j'observe c'est
qu'après une soirée évidemment samedi
avec des images qu aucun d'entre nous
n'aurait aimé voir on a à la fois l'uefa
qui lance une enquête indépendante on a
le parquet de bobigny qui lui aussi
lancent une enquête on a une mission qui
a été confiée au préfet cadot chargé de
l'organisation des grands évènements
sportifs avec dans maintenant sept ou
huit jours un rapport qui sera remis au
ministre et on a ces auditions cet après
midi
précisément pour arriver à comprendre
comment on a pu en arriver là dans un
contexte où il ya d'abord des éléments
exogènes objectif une finale qui entre
guillemets a été décidée au stade de
france ya seulement trois mois et demi
une grève sur le rer b où la crainte
d'une diminution du nombre de rames qui
a engorgé le r vrd qui a posé des
difficultés d'organisation est
manifestement du côté des supporters
anglais avec la volonté d'avoir des
billets papier etc un afflux et des
difficultés qui n'ont rien à voir avec
ce qu'on a
t côté espagnol de l'enquète les
enquêtes les audits vont permettre d'y
voir clair justement les enquêtes
commencent à peine les audits comme vous
dites
est ce que il était normal de pointé du
doigt dans et déjà les
supporters anglais est-ce qu'il ya pas
une erreur de la part de gérald darmanin
vous savez
d'abord
il ya un certain nombre d'éléments
objectifs qui accrédite le fait qu'il ya
un sujet de supporters sans billets
anglais en très grand nombre
c'est vrai dans les estimations si grand
nombre que ce qui a été dit quand vous
voyez la fédération française de
football qui hier explique qu'ils
avaient bien 35000 personnes sans billet
qui étaient aux abords du stade de
france quand vous voyez que c'est le
chiffre qui on retrouve du côté du
consortium du stade de france ou de
l'uefa et de la préfecture de police ça
fait quand même un faisceau d'indicés
j'ajoute que quand on vous dit qu'il ya
près de 3000 2800 je crois billets faux
billets qui ont été scannées alors qu'il
y avait un prêt filtrage qui consistait
des charrons d'évacuer un certain nombre
et qui avait manifestement des notes de
renseignements faisant état de
potentiellement plusieurs dizaines de
milliers de supporters anglais sans
billet je veux bien croire que tout ça
soit le fait du hasard mais ça dessine
quelque chose je veux pas justement moi
entrer dans cette espèce de réflexe
pavlovien qui fait qu'il y a des gens
qui alors que les enquêtes ne sont en
cours sont capables de vous dire de
façon extrêmement précise qui s'est
passé quand je vois l'extrême droite qui
dit c'est de la faute des racailles de
seine saint denis et l'extrême gauche
qui dit encore des violences policières
c'est une caricature précisément parce
qu'on va organiser la coupe du monde de
rugby et les jeux olympiques on a besoin
d'aller au fond des choses de comprendre
de s'assurer que le genre de chose ne
peut pas se reproduire attaquer ensuite
le ministre de l'intérieur tout ça parce
qu'on est à quelques jours des élections
législatives s'apprend en plus forcément
titien mais il ya forcément une
dimension politique gérald darmanin est
un mini skate investi extrêmement
investi pour très près de lui depuis dix
jours
y'a aucun sujet qui prend à la légère et
encore une fois je suis pas dupe de la
partie politique de tout ça mais ça ne
veut pas dire qu'il faut pas aller au
fond des choses je me réjouis qui est
des auditions je me réjouis qu'il ait
des enquêtes ça nous permettra à la fois
être sûr de comprendre et de s'assurer
que ça ne recommence pas c'est quand
même le plus important alors ce soir là
il y avait notamment une grève de la
ratp du rer b ce qui a expliqué que tous
les supporters et bien arrivés par le
rer à d c'est peut-être une des raisons
notamment de cet amas cement de public
et cette grève eh bien elle est
renouvelée pour vendredi soir pour le
match france danemark grève de la ratp
une entreprise qui est d'ailleurs
financée par une collectivité
territoriale la région ile-de-france est
ce que vous trouvez que à la
reconduction de cette grève est
irresponsable
le droit de grève est un droit
constitutionnel
il peut arriver parfois que la façon
dont on utilise deviennent
contre-productif sur le soutien du
public et je suis pas certain que de
donner le sentiment que la manière la
plus efficace d'être entendu c'est de
prendre en otage des événements de ce
type qui sont populaires et auquel les
français sont attachés soit le meilleur
moyen de faire aboutir ses
revendications mais c'est la liberté
constitutionnelle rédaction d alarme en
disant attention soyez responsable et je
suis pas là dedans je crois qu'il ya à
la fois un événement samedi dernier qui
nécessite qu'on fasse la lumière de tout
ça et puis ensuite le principe de la
responsabilité individuelle de chacun
qui vaut aussi pour ceux qui travaillent
à la ratp parce que manifestement le
fait que tous les herbes et n'est pas
circuler samedi soir n'a pas aidé à ce
qu'on ait une situation qui soit fluide
et qu'ils soient sans difficulté pour
tout le monde alors on va évoquer la
crise de l'hôpital puisque le président
de la république emmanuel macron était
hier à cherbourg chevet des soignants il
a annoncé une mission flash pour tirer
les enseignements des besoins notamment
en termes de moyens et d'effectifs dans
les différents territoires dans les
établissements il a également annoncé
une conférence sur la santé à l'été est
ce que ce sont des annonces suffisante
contenu quand même de l'urgence et puis
c'est pas nouveau on vient pas de
découvrir la crise de l'hôpital
aujourd'hui
à partir du moment où un problème est
complexe qui peut penser
que des réponses simples permettront de
le régler c'est quoi le problème de la
crise de l'hôpital c'est plein de choses
c'est pas et d'ailleurs c'est pas
seulement l'hôpital c'est effectivement
les déserts médicaux dans un certain
endroit l'insuffisante coopération entre
la médecine de ville et l'hôpital dans
d'autres parfois ce sont des soucis
d'infrastructures matérielles et prendre
un exemple très concret d'une ville que
je connais qui évidemment la ville
d'angers grâce en particulier aux ségur
de la santé un projet qui depuis des
années était dans les cartons et qui
consistait à investir massivement dans
la refonte totale de nos urgences va
pouvoir voir le jour on parle de
plusieurs centaines de millions d'euros
d'investissements parce que la première
cause aussi de l'engorgement c'était des
bâtiments inadaptée c'était des lieux
qui permettait pas de pouvoir faire les
choses dans de bonnes conditions on a
observé dans un contexte qui est celui
du vieillissement de la population la
tendance de plus en plus forte jusqu'au
qu'ovide de beaucoup de patients plutôt
que de savoir si un médecin de garde
plutôt que de savoir s'il pouvait se
rendre chez tel ou tel praticiens
d'aller tout de suite aux urgences des
caves et une difficulté ce phénomène il
a déjà amené à vendre aux vide à une
fatigue des personnels à des burnout à
des grèves à répétition dans beaucoup de
ses services avec locaux vides on a
atteint des niveaux de fatigue liée au
fait que ces soignants au lieu dans ces
moments-là de démissionner ils ont tenus
quelle que soit le nombre d'heures que
ça représentait et donc on voit bien que
pour répondre à ces soucis c'est pas
seulement répondre maintenant la fatigue
l'issue de ces 2 3 ans et répondre un
temps beaucoup plus long qui a commencé
avec un numerus clausus trop bas amnon
un renouvellement des médecins
insuffisant et qui donc aujourd'hui
nécessite de regarder les sujets de
manière transversale cette mission flash
c'est une bonne nouvelle pour plusieurs
raisons d'abord parce que sont pas que
des hospitaliers et un généraliste il ya
le samu la rsc transversale ensuite
parce qu'il s'agit pas de lancer un
comité théodule pour un an il s'agit en
l'espace de seulement 1 mois de poser un
certain nombre de constats et de faire
un certain nombre de préconisations
pourquoi seulement un mois parce que
beaucoup de ces sujets sont connues et
on va juste les rassembler dans le cadre
de cette mission flash donc de façon
très concrète sasa pardonnez-moi mais
comment ça se fait que on en est au
stade du constat alors que l'on connaît
tous les problèmes de l'hôpital ça fait
des années qu'on en parle pourquoi le
gouvernement maintenant se met à refaire
des constats je crois pas moi j'ai eu
vraiment compris les annonces du
président hier comme une agrégation des
constats et comme une compilation si
vous voulez des diagnostics pour arriver
à cette vision transversale au moment au
tout début de la crise du crédit il a
déjà été dit par le gouvernement de
l'époque on va mettre beaucoup d'argent
dans l'hôpital on en a besoin l'hôpital
va mal deux ans plus tard on en est en
effet à une mission flash est-ce que
c'est compréhensible pour les français
ça de l'argent il y en a qui a été mis
au travers du ségur de la santé au
travers du ségur de massue on
parle de milliards d'euros oui mais
parce que précisément il ne faut pas se
concentrer qu'à l'intérieur de l'hôpital
pour régler le problème de l'hôpital et
des urgences il faut être capable de
dézoomer de regarder la façon dont les
paramédicaux dont les médecins dont la
régulation dont la télémédecine s
affairant 100 rue de décharger avant
qu'on arrive à sedan lieu des insurgés
sommet plus tôt et tout est urgent ce
que je veux dire c'est que attendre que
en l'espace de quelques mois ou de
quelques semaines on règle ce qui
manifestement est un souci en terme de
deux décennies ou d'inaction de pente
dégressive
soyons raisonnables encore une fois si
tout était aussi simple s'il fallait des
baguettes magiques
pourquoi les problèmes n'ont ils pas été
réglé il ya cinq à dix il ya 15 ans
alors que si vous reprenez y compris
dans la presse quotidienne régionale les
titres des articles ça fait mes 20 ans
qu'on parle des difficultés de la
fatigue des urgentistes des des embolies
de ce genre de sujet donc encore une
fois on peut toujours considérer que ça
ne va pas assez vite ce que j'observe
c'est que il ya eu un avant et un après
que vide en terme de prise de conscience
de ce sujet et que le président de la
république avec cette visite hier à
cherbourg a bien témoigner du fait que
le sujet de la santé n'étaient pas
derrière nous mais qu'il était sur le
haut de la pile des urgences du nouveau
gouvernement alors en tout cas dans ce
contexte on a un budget de la sécurité
sociale qui est pas forcément en
meilleure posture notamment au niveau
des retraites emmanuel macron souhaite
mener une réforme des retraites le recul
de l'âge à 65 ans n'est plus un totem il
peut être revu en ça dépendra aussi des
concertations avec les partenaires
sociaux du côté de voir philippe à
l'automne dernier on était plutôt sur
une position d'un âge à 67 ans edouard
philippe fait un recul de l'âge de à la
retraite à 67 ans et ce qu'il faut
maintenir cet objectif non edouard
philippe à lancer dans le débat le fait
que quand on regarde la situation dans
les autres pays il y avait des pays dans
lesquels l'âge de la retraite est à 65
66 67 ans et il a utilisé ces trois
chiffres donc pour être très clair il ya
une grande unité dans le discours ça
consiste à dire que on peut pas faire
comme si le vieillissement de la
population n'était pas un sujet jusqu'à
maintenant au lieu de faire des réformes
autour de l'âge on a insensiblement
laisser glisser le niveau des pensions
et des retraites et dans un contexte où
le président de la république a dit
qu'il souhaitait à la fois qu' un
montant minimal de 1100 euros et qu'on
aille vers une indexation sur
l'inflation des retraites il ya bien la
nécessité de regarder la façon dont on
finance tous les pays européens autour
de nous travaille plus longtemps jusqu'à
quel âge dans quelles conditions ça va
être l'objet des concertations qui vont
être conduites par le gouvernement et
vous avez tout à fait raison de dire que
à la fois le président mais même la
première ministre ont été clairs sur le
fait que le principe d'une réforme il
est acté les modalités elles doivent
désormais dix comtés ce qu'elles vont
commencer ces discussions justement
d'abord après les élections législatives
passons à l'essentiel parce qu'on est
respectueux d'un temps qui prend tout
son sens et je pense que la première
ministre aura l'occasion sans doute dans
son discours de politique générale
d'aller précisé à la fois le contexte le
cadre le calendrier il ya déjà des
contacts informels qui ont été pris la
suite ce sera après des législatives
en préservant la public avait dit il
faut agir agir agir il annonce et même
un texte sur le pouvoir d'achat avant
législatives en texte sur
l'environnement ils se fassent rien pour
l'instant comment vous expliquez ce
temps de latence
inattendu mais il faut bien comprendre
une chose c'est que
avant de présenter un texte
c'est assez logique qui à la fois un
temps de maturation attendent
interministériel un temps de travail un
temps d'aller retour avec le conseil
d'état ou avec un certain nombre de
partenaires et donc on ne peut pas à la
fois dire il faut faire en sorte de
concerter il faut faire en sorte de
travailler avec les uns et les autres et
il faut aller plus vite la concertation
elle prend du temps et donc été un
impératif apte à trouver oui mais ce que
je veux dire c'est que même si ça peut
sembler une injonction contradictoire il
faut effectivement aller vite en prenant
le temps de la concertation et ces deux
éléments sont essentiels mais ils font
pas non plus bousculé dans une espèce de
culture de l'immédiateté dans lequel
pour répondre aux bandeaux déroulants
d'une d'une chaîne d'info en continu on
se hâterait d'aller annoncer quelque
chose
sans avoir pris le temps d'abord de
s'assurer que ça fonctionne et puis
ensuite que c'est un sujet sur lequel on
peut rassembler un pays dans lequel
aujourd'hui on a aussi besoin de cet
apaisement alors christophe béchu
l'enjeu de ces entretiens c'est aussi un
peu de voir les chantiers de ce
quinquennat pour les collectivités
territoriales d'abord un mot sur la
méthode emmanuel macron il a lancé une
méthode nouvelle pour renouer ce lien
avec les élus locaux après un premier
quinquennat ou les relations étaient
très compliquées entre le président la
république et les élus quel va être
cette méthode nouvelle
très clairement le slogan avec vous il
résume à la fois ce qu'est la
philosophie d'action du président de la
république pour ce nouveau mandat et la
manière dont elisabeth board nous a
demandé de conduire dans nos domaines de
responsabilités respectives les
chantiers que nous avons à mener dans
mon cas les choses vont être
relativement simple je vais là aussi dès
que les élections des initiatives feront
passer prendre le temps de rencontrer
toutes les associations d'élus savoir ce
qu'elles attendent de ce quinquennat et
faire en sorte de discuter des sujets
qui sont des sujets d'urgence il y en a
quelques-uns sur la table il y aura vous
le savez le dégel du point d'indicé ça
concerne aussi la fonction publique
territoriale qui représente des
effectifs très importants l'agent qui
sont au service des habitants de notre
pays dans le bloc communal c'est la
moitié des dépenses de fonctionnement
qui sont consacrés à faire ensemble de
financer les agents qui sont en première
ligne au quotidien il ya un contexte
d'inflation qui n'a échappé à personne
on se concentre beaucoup sur l'impact de
cette inflation sur les ménages mais une
commune qui chauffe une piscine qui met
du soul dans les véhicules de ces
espaces verts qui elle est elle aussi
directement confronté à un certain
nombre de ces mesures est donc il ya des
sujets qui sont tout de suite sur la
table et puis on a d'autres qui vont
arriver un peu plus tard et puis
d'autres qui sont entre les deux sont
des décrets d'application de la loi de
3ds pour lequel y en a encore plusieurs
dizaines qui sont à prendre la loi de
décentralisation
pardon la loi effectivement
décentralisation de et de simplification
qui a été porté par jacqueline gourault
et qui nécessite encore quelques zen de
mesures réglementaires pour pouvoir
entrer on appelait monsieur vous
annoncez des concertations dans un
contexte un peu particulier où emmanuel
macron annoncé 10 milliards d'économies
sur les collectivités durant ce
quinquennat est ce que c'est de nature à
apaiser les discussions avec avec les
élus locaux et puis comment on se faire
ces économies le quinquennat qui s'est
terminée il a été marqué par le fait que
non seulement les dotations en direction
des collectivités n'ont pas diminué
à la différence du quinquennat précédent
mais que de façon conjoncturelle mais
extrêmement puissante avec le plan de
relance il y a eu il y a encore des
milliards d'euros dead pour accompagner
les projets des collectivités
territoriales le président pendant sa
campagne électorale a expliqué qu' il
faudrait trouver un mécanisme pour que
les collectivités puissent participer à
un effort de modération de la dépense
publique ce chiffre il est moins
important que celui qui avait été
annoncé il ya cinq ans et il est certain
qu'on repartira pas sur les bases d'un
contrat de cahors qui consisterait à
dire il ya un pourcentage d'inflation a
pas dépassé il faudra trouver un autre
mécanisme tout simplement parce que le
contexte d'inflation dont je parlais pas
le même
mais il faut bien comprendre qu'une
collectivité locale elle vit pas sur une
île on peut pas avoir d'un côté un état
qui est confronté un certain nombre de
sujets de difficultés ou problèmes et de
l'autre des collectivités locales qui
irait bien ou inversement et surtout il
faudra que ces discussions sur les
moyens des collectivités elle soit
ordonné aux objectifs que nous
poursuivons la responsabilité qui m'a
été confié symboliquement elle est à la
fois dépendante du ministère de
l'intérieur et du ministère de la
transition écologique parce que les
collectivités locales doivent prendre
leur part et toute leur part dans la
transformation notre pays pour accélérer
sur les enjeux de l'adaptation au
changement climatique ou de lutte contre
le réchauffement va suffisamment
aujourd'hui non ça veut dire qu'il faut
gagner ça veut dire que demain dans la
façon il faudra qu'on discute à la fois
des moyens des collectivités
et ce calendrier il faudra aussi qu'on
regarde à quoi servent ces moyens et sur
ces sujets on a travaillé main dans la
main en terme de déploiement d'énergie
renouvelable en termes de lutte contre
le gaspillage en termes de capacité à
faire en sorte de lutter contre les
îlots de chaleur d'accompagnement des
populations parce qu'encore une fois
l'objectif commun d'un maire ou d'un
ministre
c'est bien beau d'être au service des
français sur les enjeux qui sont les
plus fondamentaux et cette transition
écologique c'est aujourd'hui un enjeu
fondamental donc concrètement est-ce que
cet objectif d'économies de 10 milliards
d'euros pour les collectivités
territoriales il va être maintenue du
combat même malgré le contexte de
l'inflation ou est ce qu'il va être
abaissée dans ce contexte de hausse des
prix ça fera partie de ce qui sera
évoquée dans les prochaines semaines
dans les prochains jours le chiffre il a
été annoncé sur la totalité d'un
quinquennat on est dans les premières
semaines l'a50 devant nous on peut aussi
considérer qu' il est assez logique et
légitime qu'on attende la concertation
la rencontre pour faire des annonces
dans ce domaine plutôt que de les faire
fort mieux de rencontrer les
associations d'élus représentative est
ce que les notations seront maintenues
pour les collectivités en tout cas au
même niveau est ce qu'il y aura une
baisse des notations dans ce quinquennat
vous ne me ferez pas répondre ce matin à
des sujets sur lesquels précisément
parce que je suis attachée à la
concertation et que j'ai beaucoup de
respect pour les associations qui
représentent les élus où il légitime et
logique que ce soit avec eux qu'on
évoque ces sujets dans un premier temps
à prendre quelle forme ces concertations
d'ailleurs ce sera des grandes
conférences ce sera ça prendra toutes
les formes nécessaires pour que cette
concertation soit satisfaisante à la
fois des temps de rencontre par strates
oui parce que les sujets des
départements des régions et des villes
dans un certain nombre de domaines ne
sont pas les mêmes et donc il est
logique et naturelle qu'on puisse
discuter avec les uns et les autres puis
sans doute des temps qui sont des temps
plus large parce qu'il ya aussi des
sujets qui sont transversaux et des
sujets communs une dernière question sur
ce sujet des collectivités
le retour du conseiller territorial
c'était une réforme de nicolas sarkozy
c'est à dire un conseiller qui à la fois
élu au niveau départemental et régional
est ce que cette réforme va être mise en
place dans le quinquennat écoutez encore
une fois ça fait dix jours que le
gouvernement a été annoncée on est
aujourd'hui dans la composition des
équipes on va être dans les temps de
concertation président de la république
a dit sont claires qui souhaitaient
cette réforme du conseiller territorial
les élections départementales et
régionales les arriveront à la fin de ce
quinquennat c'est pas le sujet des
premiers jours et des premières semaines
aujourd'hui il ya d'autres urgences
le programme du président il a vocation
être appliquer les engagements ils sont
faits pour être tenu et c'est
précisément la raison pour laquelle on
est très engagé dans cette campagne des
législatives pour que les français
donnent au président la majorité qui lui
permettra de tenir l'ensemble de ses
engagements et justement sur cette
campagne des législatives à christophe
béchu vous faites partie des dirigeants
du parti horizon le parti et les war
philippe quel est l'objectif dans cette
campagne pour horizon combien de sièges
vous visez à l'assemblée nationale le
plus possible parce qu'on a la
conviction que
plus la majorité sera large plus le
gouvernement le président de la
république pourront réformes et répondre
aux attentes qui se sont exprimées par
parler français le très haut niveau de
vote pour les extrêmes il traduit bien
la fois un désarroi et la nécessité
d'aller changer des choses si on veut
pas se retrouver dans la même situation
tous les cinq ans et donc pour ça il
faut une majorité pour agir une majorité
qui soit loyale une majorité aussi
qu'ils soient plurielle et qu'ils soient
diverses parce que c'est une façon
d'être capable d'écouter tous les
territoires avec un groupe horizon
important le plus important possible si
je souhaite la majorité la plus large
possible avec à l'intérieur de cette
majorité les composantes les plus larges
pour est ce que ça signifie que vous
allez apporter une petite musique
différente au sein de cette majorité
quelle quelle est la marque de fabrique
horizons est-ce que vous voterez
forcément tous les textes du
gouvernement c'est incroyable le
quinquennat n'a pas commencé et les
groupes sont pas constitués et vous êtes
déjà ce type de questions depuis le
début depuis le jour edouard philippe a
lancé son parti politique il a dit
qu'ils soutiendraient le président de la
république il n'y a pas eu d'ambiguïté
dans la constitution d'horizon sur le
fait que c'était un parti qui se
retrouvaient dans la majorité
présidentielle nous partons à ces
élections sous la même bannière avec la
même clé de financement c'est pas un
cartel électoral comme d'autres le font
pour essayer de
le duper les électeurs en leur faisant
croire qu'on est d'accord sur tout non
il ya un socle qui est celui d'une
campagne présidentielle laquelle on a
tous participé il ya un contexte qui
consiste à voir une majorité qui soit
pluriel qu'ils soient unis et qui a un
socle intangible autour des engagements
du président qu'est ce qu'apporte
horizon un ancrage territorial avec un
nom de merde en son sein
particulièrement important est le fait
d'assumer d'être un flotteur droit sur
un certain nombre de sujets notamment
régalien ou de tenue des comptes au sein
de cette majorité les choses sont
claires christophe béchu vous êtes
également le maire d'angers je voudrais
avoir votre réaction notamment autour du
drame du bal du balcon d'une cité
étudiante danger en 2016 ce balcon il
s'était effondré pendant une soirée
étudiante à cause de malfaçons bilan
quatre étudiants qui ont perdu la vie
hier le tribunal correctionnel d'angers
a condamné trois des constructeurs du
balcon mais l'architecte et le
conducteur des travaux ont été relaxés
sur le plan pénal alors que le parquet
avait quand même requis des peines de
prison à leur encontre cette relaxe elle
suscite beaucoup d'émotion notamment
auprès des familles des victimes est ce
que vous vous demandez à ce que le
parquet fasse appel
d'abord cette émotion non seulement je
la comprends mais je la partage pas ce
que c'est sans doute le pire souvenir de
mon premier mandat de maire j'étais sur
place cette nuit là
au moment où les secours s'affairaient
au moment où les familles étaient dans
l'incertitude
et l'émotion qui a bouleversé les
angevins parce que vous parlez des
quatre morts mais il ya eu beaucoup de
blessés
elle a été considérable il ya une
décision de justice qui a été rendue
hier dont je n'ai pas lu les attendus et
vous m'interrogez sur ce qui est dans la
presse
angevine de ce jour je comprends cette
émotion j'ai pas l'habitude de commenter
des décisions de justice et encore moins
d'aller expliquer au parquet ce qu'il
doit faire je lui il ya un procureur de
la république qui je pense est en train
de prendre le temps de regarder ce qu'il
ya à l'intérieur il ya une décision qui
a été étayée il ya par ailleurs pour que
les choses soient complètes
sur le plan pénal des fortunes diverses
qui ont été faits à ceux qui étaient
poursuivis mais sur le plan civil je
crois plus de deux millions et demi de
dommages et intérêts qui vont être
partagés pour le coup par l'ensemble des
prévenus avec des indemnisations
importante pour les familles qui
remplace évidemment en rien la perte de
ces jeunes hommes et de ces jeunes
femmes
mais qui permet de dire que ça n'a pas
été une irresponsabilité totale de ceux
qui ont été poursuivis
le tribunal a suivi le procureur sur la
partie civile il n'a pas complètement
suivi sur la partie pénale mais il ya
une reconnaissance claire du fait que
ces jeunes ont été des victimes et que
les familles méritent des réparations le
reste je pense qu'on y verra plus clair
dans les prochains jours merci beaucoup
aux christophe béchu d'avoir été notre
invité aujourd'hui pour votre première
interview en tant que ministre chargé
des collectivités territoriales merci
beaucoup christelle bertrand bon à voir
la une de la dépêche du midi avec cette
édition toulousaine de la dépêche
consacrée big flo et oli qui lancent
leur festival l'art aux festivals
[Musique]